le cadre est assez assez extraordinaire
entre les deux tours l'arbre magnifique
derrière et à l'ambiance
il ya les chanteurs connus c'est gratuit
et puis en plus cela chaque année on a
vu que lui il rajouté les animations
être une découverte justement ça sera
bien va avoir c'est la première fois
pourtant j'ai habité longtemps clem et
la première fois ils avaient tous deux
bonnes raisons de venir pour l'édition
2019 les clayes-sous-bois avait vu les
choses en grand écran géant au food
trucks et zone du public plus grande
l'adn c'est que c'est surtout c'est que
c'est gratuit voilà c'est un des rares
festivals qui reste gratuit voilà c'est
aussi la volonté dans un parc naturel
aussi qui est absolument magnifique
voilà c'est aussi cette idée là et puis
c'est je crois que c'est surtout placée
sur le signe de la convivialité voilà
c'est un festival qui ne veut pas que
des experts de la musique quoi c'est un
festival populaire
six artistes et groupes sur scène tout
l'après midi et la soirée comme vincent
vinel le local de l'étape anciens
candidats de the voice faisait son
premier conte soir à la maison
j'ai très très très content et très
heureux on a préparé le show comme il se
doit et on est prêt à faire du gros
spectacle et concert avec les civelles
j'y suis allé souvent bas déjà quand
j'étais plus petit ensuite j'ai présenté
le concert pendant deux ans en fait
j'étais aux premières
il ya six ans j'étais voit avec les
sybelles il ya quatre ans j'étais sur
scène
l événement a attiré plus de 18000
personnes la soirée c'est un mec un
retour dans les années 70 et 80
sur scène le groupe mythique nass wind
and fire
[Musique]